[inaudible].
I'm going to ask you a question and
don't google it.
What's the biggest agricultural power in
Europe?
Who is the biggest food export in the
entire European Union?
How many of you might think Spain,
Italy or even France after all these
countries have good weather and
thousands upon thousands of hectares of
arable land?
None of these countries though comes
close to the Netherlands,
also known as Holland.
To give you a better idea of the
Netherlands is almost the largest food
exporter in the world.
Second only to the United States,
and this is kind of a surprise because
we're talking about a country here that
is so small.
They had to build a dams to reclaim
lambs from the seed.
In fact,
it's one of the most densely populated
countries in the world to this.
We need to add the fact that they are
one of the richest ans most modern
countries on the planets.
The first stock markets was created in
Amsterdam and man's.
I'm sure all of you know Dutch companies
like Shell,
Philips or the bank.
Ing.
Normally when a country has many
industrial or service companies,
agriculture is placed on the back
burner.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
why?
Why is the Netherlands such a big food
producer?
Well,
imagine that we have a piece of land,
for example,
we'll say in Spain that measures one
hector,
if you use it to plant potatoes,
we can earn between 7,000
and 8,000
euros per hector.
Imagine instead the amount of money that
we could earn if we use that area to
build a factory or an office building.
When you do that kind of math,
that quickly becomes clear.
Why countries move away from
agriculture?
Well,
despite all of this,
Holland is the world leader of potato
exports about France above Spain,
above even the US.
And now I can probably guess what
something you're thinking agriculture in
Europe,
I mean Brussels has got to be giving out
grants somewhere,
right?
Agriculture is indeed one of the most
protected sectors with the most aid in
the entire European Union.
However,
the Netherlands isn't the country that
receives the most money.
Of course they receive aid like any
other member country,
but they don't even get a third of what
grease gets.
And if we compare it with larger
countries like France,
the difference in aid is huge.
So how is it possible that with so
nessel lambs and so little help,
Holland has become the garden of the
world?
Well,
as you can imagine,
the answer is simply explained in one
word,
technology.
In a farm in the Netherlands,
we can find a tractors that drive
themselves as drones that monitor crops
and of course resource optimization at
the highest level.
However,
there's still a question here,
why does hollins have more modern
agriculture than for example,
Spain?
Also,
what is the Netherlands done that can be
imitators in other countries?
Well today we're going to answer these
questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at their history
from the field to the university.
In the 1970s Hollands had one of the
most prosperous economies in all of
Europe.
Companies such as Phillips and Abis were
conquering the international markets.
And all of this was great news for the
Netherlands.
But as we always say on a visual
politic,
not everything was a field of racist.
Imagine being 20 years old and living in
the Netherlands back then.
Where would you have liked to work in an
international company like Phillips with
high salaries and good conditions on
your father's farm?
Well,
exactly,
Dutch agriculture.
It was on the verge of disappearing and
we also have to add something very
important to this.
As we said before,
the Netherlands is very small and
there's hardly any space for large font.
Now,
for example,
there's plenty of lands in the United
States and that means that farmers can
group and creates a large farm.
In fact,
today and lots of American farms
belonged to large corporations.
This means that they can scale
investments and by for example,
planes to fumigate huge areas of lambs.
However,
in the case of the Netherlands,
farms are small with an average size of
around seven hacks as making large
investments really very complicated.
To make matters worse.
By the seventies Dutch salaries were
already much higher than in other
European countries.
In other words,
unlike the farmers in southern Italy,
the Dutch couldn't compete with low
prices and you might be wondering now
why did they need agricor?
Sure.
After rule in those years there was
already a certain degree of
international trade.
Then Netherlands goods imports,
food while they manufacturer televisions
or bad things,
rice.
Well,
yeah,
that that is rice and from a purely
economic point of view,
they could have easily let go of their
primary sex there.
Well,
the reality is in life,
not everything is just the economy and
it's in hollins forming associations
have a lot of power more so than in
pretty much every other country.
For example,
in many other countries they have
something called the social dialogue
table,
which is an organization where the
government,
employers and unions,
meat on the Netherlands.
I have something similar at along with
employers and unions,
farmers and ranchers associations are
also welcome and in the 1970s Dutch
farmers and ranchers weren't willing to
change jobs.
So consider yourself put in this
situation,
hollins hat,
to maintain its primary sector at all
costs.
But at the same time,
all of the odds were stacked against
them.
At this point,
I know you must be thinking they did
grants.
The solution would be to simply give
subsidies to farmers so they'd stop
protesting.
Right.
This is been exactly need the first or
the last time that such policies have
been applied,
but the Dutch government,
they actually had other plans now that
they had to maintain their primary
sector.
They wanted to do it well and since they
couldn't reduce salaries or group farms,
there was only one solution left and
that was to improve productivity.
That is getting the farmers to produce
more and better food.
Well,
how did they do as well?
That's exactly what we're going to look
into right now.
The University of Bugging Meghan,
you've probably heard this sentiment is
a thousand times silicon valley wouldn't
be what it is today if it weren't for
Stanford University.
It's the Maca on research for everything
that has to do with electronics and
telecommunications,
but they don't only do research.
They also train the best computer
scientists in the world.
And when those computer scientists and
even the university,
they go directly to big companies like
Google,
apple,
and Tesla.
Well,
there's far as agriculture is concerned.
The macro of innovation isn't actually
in the u s but it's in the Netherlands.
We're talking about the University of
bargaining and also known as food
valley.
Many of you might not have heard about
this university.
That's because the only work in the
world of ag.
Right.
Gotcha.
That don't have degrees in law or art
history.
Volga nivens motto is to improve food
quality for the entire world.
So you might be wondering right now why
what's so special about this university
or the first difference is money.
The Netherlands knew that they needed
technology to improve their farming so
well,
what did they do?
Well,
they showered there.
Scientists with money in just two
decades,
the university's research budget doubled
that.
Hold on just a moment because money is
not the only important thing here.
The truth is the most important thing.
It wasn't how much but where the money
was coming,
see
in many European countries.
And then most of Latin American,
there's a very clear line that separates
public and private universities.
Public universities are funded from the
state.
Of course,
they can have some sort of collaboration
with private companies,
but that's not their main source of
funding.
Long in Nixon's case is different.
50% of their money comes from the
government,
25% from the university's own income and
to the last 25% from private companies,
and I can probably guess what you're
thinking right now.
Private company is funding a university.
Does this mean that the university is
private now?
Well,
no,
but it does bring a great advantage.
It allows the university to be connected
with the rest of society.
When we went well
preparing this video,
we had a phone call with a farmer called
sees a bravo and Spain more
specifically,
he's from the Canary Islands and we
asked you about how agricultural
modernization works.
Now,
you might not know this,
but livestock is actually very important
in the Canary Islands,
especially goats.
They have a specific type of good,
they're called the palm,
the goats,
which is unique from any other breed.
In the world.
There are actually several institutes
and foundations dedicated to studying
this specific type of goat.
However,
as Caesar explained,
practically none of the studies are
actually useful to,
I mean,
think about it.
If you have a goat farm,
what kind of research do you really
need?
As a foreigner?
You want to know how to produce more and
better milk,
so these on how to better feed the
animals,
dietary supplements or even genetic
engineering are useful.
Well,
if you go to the ICAA website,
for example,
which is the Canary Institute use of
Agricultural Research,
you won't find anything like that.
There are tons of academic articles that
explain the breed origin of the palm
egos,
whether it's related to other guys in
Morocco or Tanzania or if they existed
during the middle ages,
but price kill usage,
that kind of zeroes.
Meanwhile,
according to the times higher education
ranking Vargon Nigga and studies are the
most cited in their fields,
but that's not all.
I bet you can't guess what the
university's official languages,
given that it's in Hollands,
you'd probably be thinking they would be
speaking Dutch,
right?
Well,
no,
not at all.
We're talking about the capital of
agricultural research here and because
of this,
more than 40% of the students and
research stuff,
a foreign,
no matter where you're from,
if you have a talent in agriculture,
you can get to a place at this
university
record numbers of foreign students at
Dutch universities of technology because
of this international makeup.
The official language of the university
is English.
That explains why it bargaining and is,
for example,
a pioneer in led lamps for greenhouses,
which allows for the creation of
precisely controlled artificial
microclimates.
Thanks to this,
the Netherlands is one of the leaders in
tomato grief.
Even though in natural conditions,
tomatoes would never grow in such a cold
country and there's more here in a
country like the u s farmers need about
126 liters of water to grow one kilogram
of tomatoes.
Well,
thanks to this university's research,
now one can produce the same amounts
with just eight liters of water.
This is an incredible amounts of saving
in both economic and ecological terms.
But hold on a minute here because
research is good,
but it isn't really worth anything if it
stays within the university.
And in that regard,
the Netherlands is again,
a great example of how things are being
done right from the university to the
field.
Let's get back to Spain for a moment.
Imagine that we have a tomato garden and
we want to invest in this hydroponic
technology that will allow us to save
water,
the European Union,
or more precisely the common
agricultural policy provides all kinds
of grants so that farmers can modernize
their fields.
So we'll go to the agricultural
extension agency where all of these
grants and managed,
so the farmers getting their money there
and then they will make sure that they
spend it on improving production
techniques.
So far so good.
But how to farm know which machines to
purchase.
One would think that the farmer would
know better than anyone what their lands
would need.
But the truth is that the agricultural
wells evolves as quickly as Internet
companies.
And if nobody advises the farmer,
they'll have to find the information out
themselves.
Well,
that's the situation in which almost
every Spanish farmer has found
themselves.
There's a huge gap between the
university and the fields.
The dage case though is entirely
different.
In the Netherlands,
they have these so called agricultural
council officers.
That means that there's someone there
who will explain to the farmer what type
of machine they need to buy and what
technologies are best suited for that
type of crime.
Yeah,
and what's the result of all of this?
Well,
Dutch fields look nothing like those in
any other country.
What most of European countries consume
tons of antibiotics for their animals.
The Netherlands farmers are already
using the most advanced veterinarian
techniques in such a way that they can
prevent diseases instead of curing them.
The same happens with plants,
pesticides in this country.
They notice that if they use drones to
monitor the crops,
they can control each and every one of
the vegetables and prevent them from
becoming infected.
And in a country where almost half of
the crop,
so irrigators and they have managed to
decrease their water consumption by
almost 90% further agricultural product
exports surpassed 92 billion euros last
year.
Not any of that.
Hololens is also making money by
exporting that technology.
The United Arab Emirates goes Dutch to
ensure their food security.
So the question now becomes do you think
other countries can import these kinds
of policies?
How far in the technologies developed in
Hollins go to feed the rest of the
world?
I'll leave your answer in the comments
below and before we finish,
I'd like to thank cs a Bravo and Angel
Gogo from agq nutrition for helping us
with this video as if you're interested
in this subject,
will seem to be releasing another video
explaining the common agricultural
policy that we mentioned in this video
in depth.
Also,
don't forget to visit our friends at the
reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this video
that we're not mine and does it always
do?
Remember that we published brand new
videos every week,
so hit that subscribe button and you
won't miss a post.
And if you liked this video,
give it a thumbs up.
And as always,
I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my love
the voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com
slash podcast we'll see you there.